.
* Melancholische klassische Musik:
"Klaviertrio No. 2"
von Franz Schubert *
(Mann) Für die Jüngeren ist sie
die Kanzlerin, die immer da war,
also die ewige Kanzlerin.
Merkel war immer da -
Mutti war immer da.
Sie war ja schon fast
eine Präsidentenkanzlerin,
die über Jahre
oberhalb der Parteien,
oberhalb der innenpolitischen Kämpfe
schwebte.
In sich ruhend ist sie
eigentlich immer in gewisser Weise.
Aber ihre Position, ihre Stellung
ist doch sehr gebröckelt -
gerade im Laufe
der letzten zwei Jahre
oder der letzten drei, vier Jahre.
Insofern herrscht
ein bisschen Merkel-Dämmerung.
Heiko Sakurai
zeigt mir eines seiner Bücher,
das vor zehn Jahren erschienen ist.
Ein Bestseller in Deutschland:
"Miss Tschörmänie".
Hier ist sie
noch richtig in Siegerpose.
Das hat sich schon verändert?
Das hat sich verändert.
Zumindest in letzter Zeit, ja.
Also die unumstrittene Herrscherin
und die ungefährdete Machtposition -
das ist Vergangenheit.
Als Korrespondent habe ich
über verschiedene Regierungschefs,
Staatsoberhäupter,
Präsidenten berichtet,
diese beobachtet und begleitet.
Merkel ist besonders.
Bedacht regierend, pragmatisch
und ziemlich frei von Eitelkeit -
auch deshalb anders
als die meisten anderen.
Sie hat mich beeindruckt
und nicht selten auch verblüfft.
Mit Entscheidungen,
die von ihr kaum jemand erwartet hat.
Merkel hat Deutschland geprägt
und in Europa und in der Welt
neu positioniert.
Und sie hat
mit ihren Entscheidungen das Land,
die Gesellschaft und die Politik
verändert.
Dieser Film ist eine Reise durch
Deutschland an Orte und zu Menschen,
denen ich in den letzten Jahren
schon einmal begegnet bin
und deren Leben anders geworden ist
in Merkels
nun fast 15-jähriger Kanzlerschaft.
MIT TELETEXT-UNTERTITELUNG
Meine Reise beginnt im Osten,
in Eisenach,
wo 1685
Johann Sebastian Bach geboren wurde.
* Dynamische klassische Musik *
Über der Stadt thront die Wartburg.
Die Kanzlerin war ein Jahr alt,
als in Eisenach der erste Wartburg
in Produktion ging -
das Vorzeigeauto des DDR-Regimes.
Das Autowerk und die DDR
gibt es nicht mehr, seit 1991,
seit Deutschland Einheit ist.
Matthias Klug
war damals 14 Jahre alt.
Wir fahren zusammen
von Eisenach nach Waltershausen
durch den Thüringer Wald.
Ich staune: Die Gegend boomt.
Internationale Unternehmen sind da.
Hier sind Sie jetzt?
- Hier sind wir.
Bei Dätwyler,
einem Schweizer Unternehmen.
Hier ist Klug Geschäftsleiter.
Früher die grösste Gummifabrik
der DDR, seit 2012 in Schweizer Hand,
produzieren sie Abdichtungen für
den Tunnelbau, für Bahnen und Metros
auf dem ganzen Globus.
Sie machen die ganze Welt dicht?
- Wir machen die Welt dicht, genau.
Wir beliefern zurzeit Australien,
Russland, Kanada, USA, Südamerika.
Wir haben gerade viele Projekte
in Skandinavien.
Das ist er -
der Exportweltmeister Deutschland.
Zweittiefste Arbeitslosenquote
in der EU.
Seit Merkel Kanzlerin ist,
hat sich die Arbeitslosenzahl
von 10 % auf unter 5 % halbiert.
Wirtschaftswunder.
Viele sagen, dank Schröders
Arbeitsmarktreform, der Agenda 2010.
Klug sagt: auch dank Merkel.
Hatte Merkel diesbezüglich
einen positiven Einfluss?
Für uns ist Frau Merkel
auch sehr gut,
weil wir einen hohen Exportanteil
haben und in Märkten tätig sind,
in denen sich ein gewisser
Protektionismus einstellt,
z.B. Nordamerika, USA.
Zu diesen Ländern haben wir
nach wie vor ein sehr gutes
und offenes Verhältnis.
Und da arbeitet sie gut daran?
- Da arbeitet sie ganz gut daran.
Nach getaner Arbeit nimmt er mich mit
in die Innenstadt von Eisenach.
Der Schweizer Finanzchef des Werks
und dessen Frau sind auch dabei.
Sie schwärmen vom guten
und immer besseren Leben hier.
Ich denke, dass die Resultate
der Strukturprogramme,
die aufgelegt worden sind,
nun auch zu sehen sind.
Hat der Schweizer
in den letzten sieben Jahren
auch eine positive Entwicklung
miterlebt?
Auf jeden Fall, ja.
Wir können auch Schweizerdeutsch
sprechen. - Ja.
Man merkt schon,
dass sehr viel investiert wird.
In einigen Städten
muss noch was gemacht werden,
aber es entwickelt sich
zum Positiven.
Und die Lebensqualität
ist auch gestiegen?
Ja, definitiv.
Wir sind gar nicht mehr so weit weg
von der Schweiz.
* Dynamische klassische Musik *
Keine Stadt in Deutschland
ohne Weihnachtsmarkt.
Eine Thüringer Wurst
gibt's für 2 Euro.
Deutschland
ist günstiger als die Schweiz,
aber auch die Löhne sind tiefer,
deutlich tiefer.
2'000 Euro netto im Schnitt
bei Dätwyler.
Kann man damit hier leben?
Doch, mit 2'000 netto
kann man hier gut leben.
Im Vergleich mit der Schweiz
ist vieles billiger.
Wenn ich essen gehe,
kostet es in der Schweiz zu zweit
schnell mal einen Hunderter.
Hier sind es 20-30 Euro.
Mit 2'000 Euro
kann man hier schon leben.
Relativ tiefe Löhne,
steigende Exportzahlen
und geringe Arbeitslosigkeit -
in Eisenach ist die Welt in Ordnung.
Ich muss ganz ehrlich sagen,
ich sehe die Ära Merkel
im Nachhinein sehr positiv.
Auch für uns.
Sie handelte teilweise
mit einer gewissen Weitsicht,
teilweise vielleicht auch
mit einigen kritischen Schritten,
z.B.
die unkontrollierte Zuwanderung.
Aber prinzipiell denke ich schon,
dass sie im Sinne von Europa
und weitsichtig gehandelt hat.
Prost auf eine gute Zeit -
und auf die Kanzlerin.
Im Jahr 15 ihrer Kanzlerschaft
reden sie gut über Angela Merkel,
jene, die Teil sind
des deutschen Wirtschaftswunders.
* Nachdenkliche Klänge *
Wirtschaftswunder. Exportweltmeister.
Das ist nicht überall in Deutschland.
Für Reportagen war ich öfter
in Berlins Vorstädten,
Hellersdorf, Marzahn,
fernab vom Rausch des Aufschwungs
und der Leichtigkeit des Lebens.
Hier ist Arbeitslosigkeit
und Hartz IV.
In diesem Teil von Hellersdorf
sind 80 % der Bewohner
Sozialhilfeempfänger.
Leicht versteckt in einer
Seitenstrasse liegt die Arche.
Drinnen Kinder, die nicht teilhaben
an den DAX- und Exportrekorden
Deutschlands.
Hier kommen sie zum Spielen,
zum Basteln und zum Mittagessen.
2015 war ich in einer der 26
Arche-Einrichtungen in Deutschland,
berichtete darüber, dass 2,6 Mio.
Kinder von Transferleistungen leben
und auf Hilfe wie die Arche
angewiesen sind.
Fünf Jahre später
sind es doppelt so viele.
Die Schere hat sich weiter
aufgerissen, in ganz Deutschland.
Reich ist reicher geworden -
arm ärmer.
4,6 Mio. Kinder
leben heute in Familien,
die Transferleistungen beziehen,
denen es an Geld fehlt
für Bildung, für Freizeitaktivitäten,
für ein würdiges Leben.
Ich treffe einen der Gründer
der Hellersdorfer Arche wieder.
Hallo.
Aufgebracht darüber,
vergessen zu sein von denen,
die unweit von hier im Bundestag und
Kanzleramt entscheiden und regieren.
Die Politik versagt hier
auf ganzer Linie.
Wir werfen der Politik
auch bewusst vor,
dass sie viel zu wenig macht,
um die Kinder zu schützen.
Kanzlerin Merkel erwies sich ja
als eine sehr humanitäre Kanzlerin
in den letzten Jahren.
Hat sie zu wenig
für die Kinder gemacht?
Wir haben hier auch
viele Flüchtlingskinder.
Insofern darf ich
die Kritik auch üben.
Die Kanzlerin hat viele Menschen
nach Deutschland geholt.
Um die hat man sich gekümmert,
nicht aber um die eigenen Kinder.
Wir sprachen mit der Politik,
aber danach: Funkstille.
Ich werfe der Kanzlerin
auch ganz gezielt vor,
dass sie nichts für die Kinder tut,
die in Deutschland
in Vergessenheit geraten sind.
Wir reden hier von 4,6 Mio. Kindern,
die die Kanzlerin vergessen hat.
Sie sind eben keine Wähler.
Lea ist sieben.
Zeit ihres Lebens
kommt sie dreimal die Woche
zum Essen mit ihrer Mama.
Jessica Laue ist dreifache Mutter -
alleinerziehend, arbeitslos.
Alex, der jüngere der beiden Söhne,
ist zwölf.
Er kommt heute auch zum Essen.
Wegen eines Rückenschadens
kann Jessica nicht mehr
als Lackiererin arbeiten.
Sie ist Hartz-IV-Empfängerin
und dankbar, dass es die Arche gibt.
Sie erinnert sich an das erste Mal,
als sie hier war.
War halt komisch:
"Wie werden die reagieren?"
Aber ich wurde
liebevoll aufgenommen.
Keiner guckt einen schief an.
Und wenn die Betreuer mitkriegen,
was man mit den Sachen macht,
die man durch die Arche einspart,
kriegt man auch
eine positive Rückmeldung,
dass man einen guten Weg geht.
Mama, wann war ich
zum ersten Mal hier?
Als du ein Baby warst
und frisch geboren.
Also 2011?
- Ja.
Hellersdorf am Tag danach.
Früh am Morgen.
Hier wohnen die Laues.
Adventszeit - der Morgen erwacht
und mit ihm die Kinder.
Jessica erhält rund 1'300 Euro
für sich und die Kinder.
Damit müssen sie im Monat auskommen.
Alex träumt von einem besseren Leben.
Sonst aber alles in Ordnung?
Gut geschlafen und so? - Ja.
Mama, weisst du,
mein Ziel ist, Reporter zu werden.
Ja.
Den Wunsch hast du ja
schon lange, nicht? - Ja.
Alex wollte Äpfel.
Lea kann's kaum erwarten, das nächste
Türchen im Adventskalender zu öffnen.
Schaffst du das?
Ich kann mir was wünschen!
Wieso?
Es ist eine Sternschnuppe.
- Die ist aber gar nicht gelb.
Es sind die kleinen Dinge, über die
man sich freut bei den Laues.
Und dann Alltag:
den Grossen verabschieden,
die Kleine in die Schule bringen.
... pünktlich nach der Musikschule.
- Tschüss!
So.
Mama hat extra die Uhr um,
damit sie nebenbei läuft.
Jessica hat eine Umschulung
zur Kauffrau gemacht.
Jedes Jobangebot,
das sie seither erhalten hat,
würde weniger einbringen
als 1'300 Euro.
# La-la-la!
Willkommen
im Niedriglohnland Deutschland!
Tschüss.
Solange ich
einen Hartz-IV-Bescheid habe
und sämtliche Hilfen
in Anspruch nehmen kann,
habe ich mehr, als wenn ich
Vollzeit arbeiten würde.
Es ist extrem.
Über diesen Weg bringt man die Leute
nicht dazu, dass sie etwas tun.
* Melancholische Streichmusik *
Hartz IV heisst Verzicht -
in einem Land, in dem es alles gibt.
Wie viel Budget hast du
pro Monate fürs Einkaufen?
Pro Woche
beträgt mein Budget 50 Euro.
Letzte Woche waren wir sehr sparsam.
Deshalb gibt es heute Hawaii-Toast.
Normalerweise
gibt es nur Brot zum Abendbrot.
Aber waren wir
die Woche zuvor sparsam,
mache ich den Kindern gerne
mit ein paar Extras eine Freude.
Nachmittags
treffe ich Alex vor der Schule,
wo er täglich
für seinen Reportertraum lernt.
Er fängt von sich aus an,
mit mir über Hartz IV zu sprechen.
Hartz IV ist etwas Besonderes.
Es ist anders als bei den anderen.
Wir haben nicht das, was sie haben.
Sie können sich
alle möglichen Sachen leisten.
Sie können jedes Jahr
in den Urlaub fahren.
Wir müssen sparsam leben.
Tut dir das manchmal weh?
Es tut mir nicht weh,
ich kann damit leben.
Ich finde das ...
Klar, es ist nicht schön.
Ich kann halt nicht mitreden,
weil wir weniger haben als andere.
Aber ich kann damit leben.
Ich treffe noch einmal Jessica.
Wir reden über die Schere,
die sich weiter öffnet
in Deutschlands Gesellschaft.
Und über Angela Merkel.
Ach, die können wir vergessen.
Ihr ist nur wichtig,
dass sie im Ausland gut ankommt.
Wollen wir uns hinsetzen?
- Ja, natürlich.
Warum fühlst du dich
von Merkel nicht vertreten?
Weil Frau Merkel
und die Politik im Allgemeinen
nichts mehr
für den kleinen Mann tun.
Die tun alles für die Konzerne,
aber nichts
für den kleinen Arbeitnehmer.
Das ist nicht mehr gerecht.
Die Politik war und ist gefragt,
dafür zu sorgen,
dass das, was oben verdient wird,
auch beim Bürger unten ankommt -
und nicht umgekehrt.
Abends macht Alex Musik.
Für sich.
Und für Mama.
Merkel will man nicht mehr -
hier, wo es den Menschen weniger gut
geht als den meisten anderen.
Und ich frage mich,
wie weit die Kanzlerin selbst
von diesem Teil der deutschen
Gesellschaft entrückt ist.
15 Jahre im Kanzleramt,
Finanz-, Euro-, und Flüchtlingskrise
bewältigen,
warum kommt sie
nicht mal hierher zu Familie Laue?
Ist Merkel zu lange Kanzlerin?
Nach den Tagen
bei Jessica, Alex und Lea
werde ich das Gefühl nicht mehr los,
dass Politikerinnen und Politiker,
die zu lange in ihrer Welt leben,
zu weit weg sind vom echten Leben.
Ein Leben, das so anders ist
als jenes, das im Kanzleramt spielt.
(Angela Merkel)
Und ich sage ganz einfach:
Deutschland ist ein starkes Land.
Und das Motiv, anhand dessen
wir diese Dinge angehen, muss sein:
Wir haben so vieles geschafft,
wir schaffen das!
"Wir schaffen das" -
das ist ja der Spruch,
der Merkels Haltung
in der Flüchtlingsfrage
illustriert oder darstellt.
Der Satz wurde inzwischen
zu einem legendärem Zitat:
"Wir schaffen das!"
Keinen anderen Satz
habe ich seit dem Sommer 2015
in Deutschland öfter gehört.
Die einen zitieren ihn,
um Merkel dafür zu würdigen.
Andere,
um sich lustig zu machen über sie.
Und viele auch zynisch, weil sie
wütend sind über diesen Ausspruch.
Nahe der tschechischen Grenze,
über die Donau,
führt die Fahrt
in die Kreisstadt Deggendorf.
120'000 Einwohner.
Hier drehten wir am 11. August 2015
Bilder in der Polizeikaserne,
die zum Ankunftszentrum
für Flüchtlinge wurde.
Das war drei Wochen
vor Merkels "Wir schaffen das".
Es war jener Tag, an dem mir
zum ersten Mal bewusst wurde,
was auf Deutschland zukommen wird.
Allein an diesem Tag
kamen hier 5'000 Menschen an.
Vorwiegend aus Syrien und
Afghanistan, darunter viele Kinder.
Bilder,
die bedrückten und traurig machten.
* Sanfte Klänge *
Das Ankunftszentrum von damals
ist heute wieder eine Polizeikaserne.
Es ist ruhiger geworden, deutlich.
Wird Merkel
mit ihrer Aussage recht behalten?
1 km weiter
steht jetzt ein Ankerzentrum.
Hier warten 550 Asylbewerber
auf ihre Abschiebung.
Die bayerische AfD-Landesvorsitzende
hat mir diesen Ort
als Treffpunkt angeboten.
Im August 2015 kamen ja täglich
bis zu 5'000 hierher.
Genau. Die wurden hier
ganz schnell in Busse gepackt
und in ganz Bayern und Deutschland
verteilt.
Solche Zustände herrschen jetzt
natürlich nicht mehr.
Aber die Bevölkerung
hat hier wirklich zu leiden,
weil einiges los ist
in diesem Abschiebezentrum.
Es gibt viel Randale,
ständig Polizeieinsätze,
auch die Presse berichtet darüber,
es ist ein heisses Pflaster.
Die Bürgerinnen und Bürger
beschweren sich bei mir.
Wenn ich einen Infostand habe,
erzählen sie mir,
was hier so alles passiert.
V.a. unter den Frauen in Deggendorf
ist die Unsicherheit gross geworden.
Ebner-Steiner war CSU-Wählerin,
bis sie 2015 der national-
konservativen AfD beigetreten ist.
Zu Beginn ihrer politischen Laufbahn
stand die Flüchtlingskrise.
Ebner-Steiner hat davon profitiert.
2018 begleitete ich sie
im bayerischen Wahlkampf.
Bei der Landtagswahl schoss sie
mit ihrer Partei von 0 auf über 10 %,
was Merkel wenig später zum Rücktritt
als CDU-Parteichefin bewog.
Es war Ebner-Steiners
grösster Erfolg,
der sie zugleich isoliert hat.
Wer AfD wählt, verehrt sie -
wer nicht, verachtet sie.
Ebner-Steiner steht für den Graben,
der sich tief durch
die deutsche Gesellschaft zieht.
Welche Rolle spielte Merkel
in den letzten Jahren
bei der gesellschaftspolitischen
Entwicklung in Deutschland,
gerade auch,
was die Spaltung betrifft?
Merkel sagte: "Wir schaffen das!"
Sie sagte aber nie,
was wir wirklich schaffen wollen.
Nach der Landtagswahl in Bayern
kam Hessen,
Merkel ist dann zurückgetreten.
Sie sind eigentlich
auch mitverantwortlich,
dass sie als Pateivorsitzende
zurückgetreten ist.
Kann sein, aber Merkel
ist immer noch da und Kanzlerin.
Viele Prominente
haben Merkel damals unterstützt.
"Flüchtlinge willkommen"
war der Slogan.
Wir sind auf dem Gut Dietlhofen
bei Peter Maffay.
Einmal im Jahr öffnet er hier
die Tore für ein Bürgerfest.
Ist das für mich?
- Ja.
Oder für die Kinder?
- Für dich. - Für mich?
Der erfolgreiche deutsche Sänger
liess damals Worten Taten folgen.
Er nahm traumatisierte
Flüchtlingskinder auf seinem Gut auf.
Wenn man versucht,
sich vorzustellen,
wie sich jemand fühlt, der
in eine völlig andere Welt gerät,
in einen anderen Kulturkreis
mit einer anderen Sprache usw.,
der praktisch
wirklich bei null anfängt,
dann ist jede Hilfestellung,
die ein solcher Mensch
oder eine solche Familie
erhalten kann, sinnvoll.
Maffay zeigt mir sein Gut -
eine Kirche, neun Häuser, Ställe.
Er hat es vor Jahren
für sich erworben.
Ach, hier kommt mein Papa.
Die Herrschaften
kommen aus der Schweiz.
Aus der "Schwiiz"?
- Ja. Freut mich sehr.
Meine Frau.
- Guten Tag. Freut mich sehr.
Ebenfalls.
- Adrian. Schön.
Sind Sie stolz auf Ihren Sohn,
dass er hier so viel geschaffen hat?
Wie Bolle.
Hat lange gedauert.
Maffay war 13, als sein Vater
aus Rumänien nach Deutschland floh.
Eine Fluchtgeschichte.
Seine Fluchtgeschichte,
die ihn prägte.
2016 traf ich Peter Maffay in Köln
nach einem Konzert
mit dem Schweizer Sänger Gölä.
Wir diskutierten über die Kanzlerin -
und Maffay
lobte Merkels Willkommenskultur.
Die Message ist sehr einfach:
Freundschaft ist machbar,
über alle Grenzen hinweg.
Inzwischen sind vier Jahre vergangen
und die Sicht der Dinge
ist bei vielen eine andere geworden.
Danke schön.
Sie haben sich
in der Flüchtlingskrise exponiert.
Sie haben gesagt,
was Merkel macht, sei gut.
Haben Sie jetzt Ihre Meinung
ein wenig revidiert?
Nein, nein, nein.
Ganz im Gegenteil.
Ich bin nach wie vor völlig
davon überzeugt, dass ein Land,
das viel zu bieten hat
und vieles im Überfluss besitzt,
davon etwas abgeben soll.
Wenn man dann allerdings sieht,
wie viele dieses System,
unser System, unseren Staat,
unsere Leistungsfähigkeit,
das Involvement der Menschen hier,
missbrauchen,
dann muss man das unterbinden.
Angela Merkel
wird spätestens 2021 aufhören.
Werden Sie der Kanzlerin nachtrauern?
Nachtrauern
ist ein überzogener Begriff.
Wir haben ja neulich
darüber gesprochen.
Sie haben mir die Frage gestellt,
ob es gut war oder nicht,
was sie getan hat,
wie man sie
in Erinnerung behalten wird.
Ich habe darauf geantwortet:
"Wahrscheinlich besser,
als es manchmal den Anschein hat."
Das sehe ich wirklich so.
Aus humanistischer Sicht
hat sie das einzig Richtige gemacht.
Man würde ihr Unrecht tun,
wenn man behaupten würde,
sie hätte
einen schlechten Job gemacht.
Drei Fahrstunden weiter ostwärts
liegt Bad Kötzting.
Im Flüchtlingsheim
der bayerischen Kleinstadt
leben 30 Nationen zusammen.
In diesem ehemaligen Krankenhaus
warten sie auf ihren Bescheid:
bleiben dürfen oder gehen müssen.
Im Januar 2016 berichtete ich
über die ehrenamtlichen Helfer
in den Heimen in Bayern.
Tausende leisteten in den
ersten Monaten der Flüchtlingskrise
an Ausgabestellen und in provi-
sorischen Schulzimmern Hilfsarbeit.
... sprechen.
In Bad Kötzting
waren es damals 60 Freiwillige.
Davon sind heute
noch 20 übrig geblieben.
Eine von ihnen ist Brigitte Ertl.
Sie koordiniert
die freiwilligen Helfer,
ist die gute Seele,
Helferin, Vertrauensperson,
seit der ersten Stunde -
für alle, die hier stranden.
Dieses Baby ist bei uns geboren.
Ich bin schon Taufpatin geworden.
Wir haben Hochzeiten,
wir haben Geburten,
wir haben alles,
was Sie sich nur vorstellen können.
Bei uns sprüht alles voller Leben.
Ein Leben im Heim,
wo sie teils schon
seit Beginn der Flüchtlingskrise
auf ihren Asylentscheid warten.
Viele Afrikaner,
weil Syrer, Afghanen und Iraker
prioritär beurteilt wurden.
Vor fünf Jahren waren Behörden
und Helfer in ganz Deutschland
völlig überfordert.
Heute ist es anders.
Mehr als 1 Mio. Menschen
sind gekommen.
Passt das zusammen, wird das
zukünftig in Deutschland passen -
schafft Deutschland das?
Es geht hier nicht ums Schaffen -
man wird es nicht aufhalten können.
Wir werden das  m ü s s e n ,
denke ich.
Wir kommen ja nicht raus
aus dieser Mühle.
Die Leute kommen,
werden aufgenommen ...
Wenn Sie schauen,
wie viele zurückgeschickt werden -
das steht ja in keiner Relation.
Sie haben gesagt: "Wir müssen."
Sind Sie optimistisch,
dass es dann auch funktioniert?
Wenn alle am selben Strick ziehen,
funktioniert es.
Wenn die negativen Meinungen
verstummen, funktioniert es.
Nicht jeder
muss seine Meinung komplett ändern.
Es braucht nur ein bisschen
Menschlichkeit von jedem -
dann funktioniert es.
Immer öfter bleiben Zimmer im
Flüchtlingsheim in Bad Kötzting leer.
Es kommen weniger.
Noch 165'000 stellten 2019
einen Asylantrag in Deutschland.
Rund 1 Mio. der Flüchtlinge, die
seit 2015 bis heute angekommen sind,
werden in Deutschland bleiben.
Haben Sie noch eine gute Meinung
von der Kanzlerin?
Ja, doch.
Nur wegen der Flüchtlingswelle
ist sie keine schlechte Kanzlerin.
Frau Merkel
war eine gute Kanzlerin -
nicht besser und nicht schlechter
als alle ihre Vorgänger.
Hat sie Ihnen vielleicht
zu viel zugemutet?
Sie hat ihren deutschen Bürgern
schon sehr viel zugemutet -
ja, das muss ich schon sagen.
Zu viel?
Wenn man die politische Landschaft
anschaut, dann ja.
Merkel habe humanitär richtig
gehandelt, höre ich immer wieder.
Und ich teile diese Meinung.
Aber hat Merkel die Zahl
der Ankommenden unterschätzt
und die Solidarität
innerhalb der EU überschätzt?
Viele Menschen zweifeln bis heute,
dass sich Afrikaner, Syrer, Afghanen
im organisierten, wertbewussten
und ordnungsliebenden Deutschland
integrieren können.
Diese Zweifel
haben die Gesellschaft gespalten -
und diese Spaltung
hat die Politlandschaft verändert.
* Erhabene Klänge *
Was lange unvorstellbar war
in Deutschland,
ist in Merkels Kanzlerschaft
Wirklichkeit geworden:
Eine patriotische,
nationalkonservative Partei
konkurriert
die grossen Volksparteien.
Die AfD
feiert Wahlerfolg um Wahlerfolg.
Es ist ein heisser Spätsommertag
im Jahr 2019.
Am 1. September aber soll es frostig
werden für die Regierungsparteien.
Die AfD will erstmals stärkste Kraft
werden in einem Bundesland -
in Brandenburg.
Im Februar 2016 besuchte ich eine
Wahlveranstaltung der AfD im Osten.
Ein paar Dutzend Parteifreunde
in einem kleinen Schützenhaus.
Ich konnte mir
damals nicht vorstellen,
dass die erst 2014 gegründete Partei
so schnell wachsen würde.
Ich bin auf dem Weg
nach Werder an der Havel,
wo die Alternative für Deutschland
zum Wahlfest lädt.
Ein Fest mit viel Polizei,
die Zäune aufstellt.
Gespaltene Gesellschaft,
gespaltenes Deutschland -
seit dem Aufschwung der AfD.
Am Ort, genannt Bismarckhöhe,
in Vorfreude Parteimitglieder.
Unten an den Zäunen Bürgerinnen
und Bürger mit ihren Kindern,
die die AfD nicht wollen.
(Sprechchöre) Haut ab, haut ab!
Auf Sichtdistanz: die AfD-Jugend.
* Erhabene Klänge *
Wie ist das für euch,
wenn ihr seht, wie protestiert wird,
und euch die Leute
als Nazis niederschreien?
Das ist total witzlos.
Wenn Sie sich
die Protestleute anschauen,
das sind kleine Kinder,
um die zehn Jahre alt,
die wissen gar nicht, was sie sagen.
Und ... ähm ...
Die werden aufs Übelste missbraucht.
Das ist aber
keine echte Gefahr für uns.
Man hat ja
die freie Meinungsäusserung.
Ich habe kein Problem damit,
wenn man gegen eine Partei ist.
Das macht Demokratie auch aus.
Man muss nicht immer
auf der gleichen Linie fahren.
Sie sollen ruhig
ihre Meinung kundtun.
Aber wenn man selber
mit Schimpfwörtern -
was heisst hier Schimpfwörter -,
wenn man selber
als Verbrecher denunziert wird,
dann ist es was anderes.
Ich selber fühle mich nicht so.
Ich meine, wir machen hier Politik.
Kurz vor 18 Uhr kommt Björn Höcke.
Der neue starke Mann der AfD,
weit rechts aussen,
und damit v.a. im Osten erfolgreich.
Ganz vorsichtig optimistisch.
Genau, vorsichtiger Optimismus
ist genau richtig.
Um 18 Uhr: die Resultate.
* Jubel *
Die AfD wird zweitstärkste Kraft
im Bundesland,
knapp hinter Merkels CDU
und deutlich vor allen anderen.
Viele haben am Ende des Wahlkampfes
ja gesagt,
sie freuen sich schon darauf,
wenn es vorbei ist.
Gar nichts ist vorbei:
Jetzt geht's erst richtig los!
Es geht erst richtig los!
* AfD-Sprechchöre *
Viele im Saal träumen vom Regieren.
Aber niemand
will mit Ihnen regieren.
In der Politik
sind drei Tage eine Ewigkeit.
Wir spüren alle,
wie sich die politische Lage im Land
beschleunigt, sich dynamisiert.
Keiner weiss, was in ein
oder zwei Jahren hier los ist.
Wir halten uns bereit,
machen uns stark und kämpfen weiter.
Welchen Anteil hat die Kanzlerin
an Ihrem heutigen Erfolg?
Die Kanzlerin? Na ja ...
Die Ära Merkel
geht heute definitiv zu Ende.
hat Deutschland ausgezehrt.
Auf allen
relevanten Politikfeldern -
sei das die Einwanderungspolitik,
die Euro-Rettungspolitik
oder die Energiewendepolitik -
wurden fundamentale Fehler gemacht,
die Deutschland
schwer geschadet haben.
Die Menschen spüren, dass dunkle
Wolken am Horizont aufziehen,
dass es so nicht weitergehen kann.
Insofern haben Angela Merkel
und alle Parteien,
die ihr noch folgen,
und das sind fast alle Parteien,
indirekt - leider muss man sagen -
einen Anteil am Erfolg der AfD.
Die einst verlachte Splitterpartei
AfD ist Volkspartei.
Überrascht bin ich heute nicht.
Vor fünf Jahren hätte ich es aber
nicht für möglich gehalten.
Die Flüchtlingskrise hat der AfD
den entscheidenden Auftrieb gegeben,
ihr Hunderttausende Unzufriedener,
aber auch Wertkonservativer
in die Arme getrieben.
Jene, die so gar nichts mehr
am Hut haben mit den Regierenden,
mit Merkel.
* Dramatische Klänge *
In der früheren Bundeshauptstadt Bonn
treffe ich Alexander Mitsch.
Er nimmt mich mit zu einer
Veranstaltung der WerteUnion,
die er gegründet hat.
Eine innerparteiliche
konservative Gruppe,
die eine Politikwende will
in der CDU, die heisst: ohne Merkel.
Der entscheidende Kernpunkt ist:
Niemand weiss, wofür die CDU
im Moment eigentlich noch steht.
Warum soll ich die CDU wählen?
Damit einher
geht eben diese Profillosigkeit.
Frau Merkel hat den
konservativen Wirtschaftsliberalen
über Jahre hinweg
die Heimat in der Partei genommen.
Mitsch meint damit Grundsatz-
entscheidungen der Kanzlerin,
mit welchen sie in seinen Augen
konservative Prinzipien
mit Füssen getreten hat.
Die Einführung der Rente mit 63,
die Abschaffung
der allgemeinen Wehrpflicht,
den Ausstieg aus der Kernenergie,
ihre offene Haltung
zur gleichgeschlechtlichen Ehe -
und natürlich ihre Asylpolitik.
Mitsch hat in Bonn eine Veranstaltung
organisiert zum Thema:
aus den Fehlern
der Asylpolitik lernen.
Geladen hat er Hans-Georg Maassen,
den früheren
Verfassungsschutzpräsidenten,
der wegen Kritik
an Merkels Flüchtlingspolitik
zurücktreten musste.
Dass Maassen kommt,
passt nicht allen.
Da drüben haben Sie schon
ein Willkommensplakat.
Es ist ja in Ordnung,
wenn jemand der Meinung ist,
dass refugees welcome sind -
das kann man politisch vertreten.
Nicht in Ordnung ist,
wie Herr Maassen beleidigt wird.
Das überschreitet
das vernünftige Mass
einer politischen
Auseinandersetzung.
Diese Einwanderungspolitik
hat zu einer Radikalisierung
der Politik in Deutschland geführt.
Ein junges Mitglied der WerteUnion
entfernt das Plakat.
* Ruhige Musik *
Im Winter 2018
begleitete ich Alexander Mitsch
zu einer Gründungsversammlung
der WerteUnion in Baden-Württemberg.
Damals kam ein gutes Dutzend Leute,
welche innerhalb der CDU
Merkels Kurs infrage stellten.
Heute zählt Mitschs WerteUnion
fast 4'000 Mitglieder
Ein anderer Eindruck
als beim letzten Mal, nicht?
Ja. Die Säle werden grösser.
Absolut. Wir merken, dass wir
auf der richtigen Welle sind
und die Menschen
unsere Überzeugungen teilen.
Und die Menschen kommen heute
in Scharen, um Maassen zu hören.
Der stellt so ziemlich alles infrage,
wie Deutschland, wie die Regierung,
wie Merkel in der
Flüchtlings- und Asylpolitik agiert.
Die Frage ist: Ist die fehlgeleitete
Asylpolitik korrigierbar?
Ich bin der Meinung:
Sie ist korrigierbar.
Ich glaube,
die Mutter aller Probleme
ist der fehlende politische Wille,
Realitäten zu erkennen,
Probleme zu erkennen
und diese Probleme
dann lösen zu wollen.
Ich bin zuversichtlich,
dass wir als WerteUnion die Gewinner
der Geschichte sein werden.
Herr Mitsch und Herr Maassen,
zufrieden, wie es heute lief?
Hervorragend.
Die Leute waren begeistert.
Wir haben vielen
aus der Seele gesprochen.
In zwei Jahren
sind wir dann dreimal so viele.
Hat die Kanzlerin
Sie in die Politik getrieben?
Ich war immer
ein politisch denkender Mensch.
Auch als Verfassungsschutzpräsident
habe ich schon politisch gedacht.
Aber jetzt
habe ich eine gewisse Freiheit,
auch politisch zu wirken,
und deshalb tue ich es auch.
Wird es denn besser,
wenn Frau Merkel weg sein wird?
Es wird anders werden.
Ich hoffe auf eine Politikwende.
Herzlichen Dank, Herr Maassen.
- Bitte schön.
Maassen und Mitsch
wollen nicht mehr mit Merkel,
weil sie ihnen
zu weit nach links gerückt ist.
Beim Weggehen erzählt mir Maassen,
dass er gerne in die Schweiz komme,
dort könne er sehr offen mit Bürgern
und Politikern über Migration reden.
Innerparteiliche Akteure wie er
werden weiter daran arbeiten,
Merkels Ende
vorzeitig herbeizuführen.
Machen Sie's gut.
- Sie auch.
Danke schön. Tschüss.
Im Juni 2011 hat die Kanzlerin
eine Entscheidung getroffen,
die stark zur Entfremdung
zwischen Merkel
und den Wertkonservativen in der CDU
beigetragen hat.
Merkel, die Physikerin, hat
nach dem Reaktorunglück in Fukushima
den Atomausstieg beschlossen
und damit die Energiewende.
Fukushima hat meine Haltung
zur Kernenergie verändert.
Seither sind allein
im Nordosten Deutschlands
Tausende Windparks entstanden.
Ganz viele davon
hat Karsten Porm geplant und gebaut.
Mind. 180.
Ein Understatement.
In Wirklichkeit sind es viel mehr.
2016 besuchte ich Porm schon einmal,
die Produktion lief auf Hochtouren.
Er und seine Leute
bauten und bauten und bauten.
Heute steht die Produktion still.
Vorübergehend.
Man hat zum einen lange Planungs-
zeiten für Windenergieprojekte,
Vorlaufzeiten von drei bis fünf
Jahre für ein Windenergieprojekt.
Und die Überbürokratisierung
des Genehmigungsverfahrens
führt zu sehr schleppend
einlaufenden Genehmigungen.
Die deutsche Bürokratie
bremst den Bauboom aus.
Nicht aber Windradbauer Porm.
Er plant und produziert
auch in Frankreich und in Schweden.
Deutsche Windradbauer sind
zu Vorreitern in Europa geworden,
auch weil Merkel die Bedeutung
von Klima und Nachhaltigkeit
in der Politik
früher erkannt hat als andere.
* Bedächtige Klänge *
Porm nimmt mich mit
zu einer seiner Anlagen,
genauer  a u f  eine seiner Anlagen.
137 m hoch
mit Blick auf seine Windparks.
Das ist schon eindrücklich.
V.a. können sie schön weit
in die Landschaft gucken.
2022 soll das letzte AKW vom Netz,
in Zeiten, in denen Deutschland
immer mehr Strom braucht.
Klappt das?
Wenn wir uns
den bisherigen Weg anschauen
und was wir schon alles
geschafft haben -
im Westerwald würde man sagen:
"Wir lassen doch jetzt das Messer
nicht in der Sau stecken."
Wir sollten nicht
auf halber Strecke aufgeben.
Wir schaffen das,
wir kriegen das zu Ende.
Es ist diese Überzeugung, die ich in
diesem Land immer wieder mitbekomme.
Dennoch habe ich Zweifel,
dass der schnelle Atomausstieg die
richtige Entscheidung Merkels war.
Deutschland ist zwar Pionier
bei den Erneuerbaren,
der Entscheid hat aber auch
Merkels Partei weiter entzweit.
Und viele befürchten, dass dem Land
bald der eigene Strom ausgehen wird.
Denn auch in der Lausitz
soll bald einmal Schluss sein.
Hier mit der Kohle.
Ich bin auf dem Weg
zum Tagebau Schwarze Pumpe.
2014 besuchte ich das Dorf Proschim.
Es stand kurz davor, wegzukommen,
damit man die Kohle
unter dem Dorf abbauen kann.
400 Familien
sollten umgesiedelt werden.
Die Regierung wollte
wieder vermehrt auf Kohle setzen
nach dem beschlossenen Atomausstieg.
Jetzt ist wieder alles anders.
Und das hier ist das Dorf Proschim?
- Ja, das ist das Dorf Proschim.
Proschim bleibt.
Dafür soll nun der Tagebau weg.
Jenes Feld und jene Weiten,
wo die Menschen in der Lausitz,
wie Dieter Freissler,
seit Jahrzehnten Kohle abbauen -
für Energie im ganzen Land.
Was bedeutet die Kohle
für die Region, für die Lausitz?
Die Kohle war über Generationen
Arbeitgeber.
Ganze Generationen
haben damit ihr Geld verdient.
Und wenn damit fertig ist,
ist es vorbei.
Abgebaute Kohleerde -
weiter als das Auge reicht.
Ein surrealer Anblick über ein Feld,
das spätestens 2038
stillgelegt sein soll.
Oder früher.
Denn die Kohlegegner von Ende Gelände
fordern Ende mit Schwarze Pumpe.
Und zwar sofort.
Weil durch Kohleenergie
zu viel CO2 ausgestossen werde.
In den umliegenden Dörfern
versammeln sich die Bewohner
am gleichen Abend zu Mahnwachen.
Für die Kohle.
Für die Schwarze Pumpe.
Für ihre Existenz.
Die sie nicht hergeben wollen
in der Lausitz.
Ihr Vereinslokal
heizen die aktiven Kumpels
und die in Rente
natürlich mit Kohle.
Briketts vom Tagebau.
Einmal im Monat treffen sie sich.
Die Kohle hier niederzumachen,
bis 2038 abzuschalten, ist falsch.
Wir wissen nicht, wie es mit Arbeit
in der Region weitergehen wird.
In den Dörfern
sind immer weniger Leute.
Wir waren mal 500 Menschen im Dorf,
jetzt sind es noch 265.
Aus den Worten der Kumpels höre ich
Zukunftsangst und Verunsicherung.
Und Merkel ist für sie jene,
die ihnen die Zukunft nimmt.
Von der halten wir gar nichts mehr.
Liebe Frau Bundeskanzlerin,
das war eine Alleinentscheidung.
Ohne Not, das muss man ja mal sagen.
# ... und er hat sein helles Licht
bei der Nacht,
# und er hat sein helles Licht
# schon angezünd't, schon angezünd't.
# Hat's angezünd't!
Wie die Flüchtlingsfrage
spaltet auch die Energiewende
das Land und die Gesellschaft.
Merkel hat diesen Entscheid nach
dem Unglück in Fukushima beschlossen.
Emotional geleitet -
wie in der Flüchtlingskrise.
Beide Entscheidungen hat sie
nicht kalkuliert und berechnet -
wie sonst so alles
in ihren Kanzlerjahren.
Beide Entscheidungen
haben tiefe Gräben aufgerissen
in der deutschen Gesellschaft.
* Erhabene Klänge *
Und dann ist da noch die SPD,
Merkels Koalitionspartnerin.
Seit 2014 im Sinkflug.
Während Merkel die CDU 18 Jahre lang
als Parteichefin
fast unumstritten führte,
hat die SPD zehnmal
den Vorsitzenden ausgewechselt
und ist von 35 %
auf 14 % Wähleranteile abgestürzt.
Ich bin in Brieselang in Brandenburg
bei Genossen, die der SPD treu sind.
Gründerväter der Partei
im Osten nach der Wende,
die sich heute regelmässig
im Wintergarten
von Norbert Jütterschenke treffen,
dem Vorsteher des SPD-Ortsvereins.
2017 - nach der Bundestagswahl -
besuchte ich sie schon einmal,
als es darum ging, ob die SPD noch-
mals in eine Regierung treten soll,
zusammen mit Merkel
in die Grosse Koalition.
Schon damals waren sie skeptisch.
Zwei Jahre später
sitzen sie wieder hier.
Ihre Partei
regiert immer noch mit Merkels Union
und ist noch weiter abgestürzt.
Man muss sich schämen dafür,
wo wir gelandet sind.
Mir fehlt
eine Führungspersönlichkeit.
Eine starke Frau wie Merkel
hat die SPD nicht.
Merkel
hat die CDU sozialdemokratisiert,
das sagen viele.
Sie hat die CDU
weit nach links gesetzt.
Und sie erntet als grössere ...
als eigentliche Regierung,
als Bundeskanzlerin, das,
was die SPD zustande gebracht hat.
Das ist eigentlich irre.
Viele Genossen fragen sich,
wofür sie sich abstrampeln,
während sie sich hinstellt -
hier ein Orden, da ein Orden:
"Ich bin die Grösste."
Guido Speer zog die Reissleine.
Im letzten Sommer
schrieb er auf Facebook,
dass er seine SPD-Ämter niederlege.
Er habe keine Lust mehr,
ein totes Pferd zu reiten.
Zwei Monate später
treffe ich ihn wieder. In Berlin.
Die Genossen halten Parteitag,
und Speer will zurück
zu seiner alten Liebe.
In die neue Zeit?
Ich bin nicht so
der Freund von Slogans.
So, was wird das hier -
die Rolltreppe ins Glück?
Das könnte es sein, nicht?
- Das könnte es sein, ja.
Oder zumindest die Rolltreppe
in eine bessere Zukunft.
Das hofft man zumindest.
Andererseits: Schlechter
kann es nicht mehr werden.
Noch schlechter wäre 5 %.
Ist man heute auch besorgt
als SPD-Mitglied?
Na ja, besorgt ...
Man fragt sich, wie es weitergeht.
So, jetzt sind Sie zu Hause?
- Jetzt bin ich zu Hause, ja.
Wenn Sie so sagen "zu Hause" ...
Ist es noch Liebe,
die Sie zur SPD haben?
Liebe, was ist Liebe?
Ich liebe
meine Frau und meine Kinder.
Aber ansonsten ...
Es ist eine gewisse Art von Heimat,
die ich mir 1989 ausgesucht habe.
Ich bin ja freiwillig eingetreten.
Aber es tut weh,
wenn die Heimat versaut wird.
Schauen wir mal.
Und dann rein ins rote Herz.
Die SPD wählt
eine neue Parteiführung. Wieder.
Diesmal eine Doppelspitze:
Norbert Walter-Borjans
und Saskia Esken,
die einen neuen Kurs weiter
nach links, weg von Merkels Mitte,
eine neue Zeit versprechen.
Wieder.
Hört ihr die Signale?
Die neue Zeit, sie ruft.
Wo steht denn die SPD in fünf Jahren?
Ich glaube nicht,
dass wir den Kanzler stellen werden.
Aber wir werden - hoffentlich -
weiterhin in der Regierung sein
und eine wichtige Rolle spielen,
da bin ich mir sicher.
Die SPD leidet,
sucht ihren Weg neben Merkel.
Ist die SPD wirklich Opfer
von Merkels pragmatischem Kurs?
Oder nur Teil der Krise
der europäischen Sozialdemokratie?
Oder fehlt ihr
einfach eine Leaderfigur?
Es ist wohl von allem etwas,
was die SPD zu dem gemacht hat,
was sie heute ist:
eine 14-%-Partei -
in der Hoffnung auf eine neue Zeit,
in der es besser wird,
wenn Merkel einmal weg sein wird.
Merkel weg?
Im Herbst 2021 will sie
aus dem Kanzleramt ausziehen -
irgendwie unvorstellbar.
Wer soll ihr nachfolgen?
Ich fahre zur CDU-Parteichefin
Annegret Kramp-Karrenbauer
in die Machtzentrale der CDU,
ins Konrad-Adenauer-Haus,
wo sie uns zum Gespräch lädt.
Was ich an diesem Abend
noch nicht weiss:
Zwei Wochen später
wird sie ankündigen,
dass sie als Kanzlerkandidatin
nicht zur Verfügung stehe.
Hier haben Sie sonst
die Vorstandssitzungen? - Ja.
Und die Vorstandsvorsitzende
ist immer ...
Dort, wo das Mikrofon steht,
sitzt in der Regel die Kanzlerin,
und ich daneben.
2017 traf ich sie im Saarland.
Damals war sie dort
Ministerpräsidentin -
im Wahlkampf für Merkel.
Sie ist enge Vertraute der Kanzlerin.
Merkel machte sie
zur Generalsekretärin
und zur Parteichefin -
eine von Merkels Gnaden,
die nun die CDU führt.
Eine Partei, die 2014 noch
41 Wählerprozent hatte, jetzt 27,
der viele den Rücken gekehrt haben,
v.a. Struktur- und Wertkonservative.
Hat Angela Merkel Ihre Partei
zu weit nach links gezogen,
gesellschafts-
und wirtschaftspolitisch?
Ich kann mit diesen Kategorien
rechts und links wenig anfangen.
In all den Jahren
hat es Angela Merkel geschafft,
die Partei an die gesellschaftlichen
Veränderungen anzupassen.
Die Realität verändert sich.
Eine Partei, die mehrheitsfähig
in der Mitte sein will,
muss sich mit dieser Realität
auseinandersetzen
und Antworten geben,
die die Menschen 2020 überzeugen
und nicht diejenigen, die etwa 1950
die CDU toll gefunden haben.
Das ist eine Herausforderung,
an der jeder Vorsitzende
und jede Vorsitzende
zu arbeiten hat, so auch ich.
Frau Merkel hat sich gefreut,
als Sie Parteivorsitzende wurden.
Würde Sie sich auch freuen,
wenn Sie Kanzlerin werden?
Das müssen Sie Frau Merkel fragen.
- Möchten Sie?
Ich möchte dafür sorgen,
dass die CDU so stark abschneidet,
dass wir wieder die Kanzlerin
oder den Kanzler stellen.
Aber die logische Kandidatin
ist die Parteivorsitzende, Sie.
Die Parteivorsitzende
führt diesen Prozess von vorne.
Entschieden wird Ende Jahr
auf dem Parteitag.
Die Aktualität hat uns
bei den Dreharbeiten überholt.
Nach dem Wahlfiasko in Thüringen
wird sie nicht mehr Kanzlerin.
Und Merkels Abgang
könnte früher kommen als angekündigt.
Wann immer das sein wird.
Merkels Vermächtnis ist ein Land,
das wirtschaftlich glänzend dasteht,
in dem aber zu viele Menschen
zu tiefen Löhnen arbeiten müssen
und deren Kinder in Armut leben.
Merkels Vermächtnis
ist auch ein Land,
in dem sich die Parteienlandschaft
grundlegend verändert hat,
in der die beiden einst
staatstragenden Volksparteien
nicht mehr zwingend
den Anspruch geltend machen können,
den Kanzler oder die Kanzlerin
zu stellen.
Merkels Vermächtnis ist auch die AfD,
die neben
der einst alternativlosen Kanzlerin
rasant eine Alternative
werden konnte.
* AfD-Sprechchöre *
Merkels Vermächtnis
ist aber auch ein Deutschland,
das wirtschaftlich und politisch ein
tragender Grundpfeiler geworden ist
für Europa.
Humanitär hat sie Massstäbe gesetzt.
Und sie hat Sorge getragen
zu Deutschland und zu Europa -
mit ihrem unvergleichlich
pragmatischen Regierungsstil.
Nach 15 Jahren an der Macht
hat Angela Merkel in ihrem Land
noch immer Zustimmungswerte
von nahezu 70 %.
Auch das ist ein Vermächtnis.
SWISS TXT AG / Access Services
Philipp Schlatter - 2020